and you can see it in the media all the
time like every poor decision a woman
makes like you see it in the media like
for example like women gain weight right
what body positivity that's the next
thing that comes out we just talked
about that Jordan Peterson yeah the one
big girl was on the cover of SI yeah and
and I've been overweight and that you
can lose it so why are we tripping like
why are we tripping and and they do the
same thing with age now too you see them
pushing like what are the ageism that's
the new word oh yes because the older
women are upset that they're lonely yeah
yeah they're mad that they're not
getting the same sexual offers that they
were getting in their youth it's
shocking yeah